غضب شعب كبير يرافقه توتر امني وتحذيرات
من انفجار الوضع في زاهدان على خلفيه
اعتقال رجل الدين السني مولوي مراد زاهي
حملات النشطاء البلوش في ايران اعلنت ان
اجواء مدينه زهدان اصبحت امنيه وملتهبه
اكثر من اي وقت مضى وقد تشهد انفجارا
كالبركان حسب وصف الحمله بدورها علقت
وسائل الاعلام مواليه للنظام الايراني
التي نشرت ان السبب اعتقاله هو اتهامات
مثل تظليل الراي العام ومحاوله تشويه سمعه
النظام واعتبر موقع حاله اعتقال مولاوي
عبد المجيد بانها على ما على دخول النظام
مرحله جديده لاختبار الشعب لب الشيء
محذرتاه من انفجار الاحتجاجات في بلوشستان
مضيفه ان النظام بهذه الخطوه باتا اكثر
جراءه على القمع والترهيب والقيام
باعتقالات واسعه النطاق وطبعا خلق الم من
الخنق في المجتمع الامر الذي وصفه الموقع
بانها سياسه تهدف لتهديد المؤثرين الذين
يحضون باحترام المجتمع الايراني وبالحديث
هنا عن المؤثرين وعمليه الترهيب التي
يتعرضون لها في ايران حكم النظام على كل
من المدونه الايرانيه السياج حقيقي
وخطيبها امير محمد احمد بالسجن عشر سنوات
ونصف لكل واحد منهما بعد نشره مع هذا
الفيديو الذي يرقصون فيه بساحه ازاي
بتهران واتهمت محكمه الثوره في ايران
المدونين بالترجيع على الفساد والدعاره
وفقا لايران انترنت
[موسيقى]